rrèglement entrera en vigueur
dadans 18 mois soit en février
202024.
D Depuis le 23 juillet dernier,
c'c'est le retour des Perséides
dadans tout l'hémisphère nord.
LaLa célèbre pluie annuelle
d'd'étoiles filantes connaîtra
àà partir de ce soir son record
d'd'activité, à la plus grande
jojoie des amateurs  d'astronom.
PlPlusieurs activités sont
d'd'ailleurs prévues
àà l'Astrolab du parc national
dudu Mont-Mégantic.
PoPour en parler nous recevons
SéSébastien Giguère, coordonnatr
scscientifique à l'observatoireu
paparc du mont Mégantic. Comment
çaça se profile cette année. Es-
cece que les conditions
d'd'observation sont bonnes?
- - Ça dépend toujours un peu de
nonotre sens de l'émerveillement
pepersonnel. La réponse, c'est
ououi, mais il faut effectivemet
cecette année faire une petite
prprécaution, au sens où la lune
sesera très présente cette anné,
dodonc question de calibrer les
atattentes, c'est sûr que le
nonombre d'étoiles filantes alos
ququ'on pourra avoir sera
ininférieur à ce qu'on peut voir
lolorsque la lune n'est pas
prprésente, ce qui évidemment ne
veveut pas dire que le spectacle
n'n'en vaudra pas la peine, au
cocontraire. Donc normalement, a
plpluie d'étoiles filantes des
PePerséides, on parle d'un taux
d'd'étoiles filantes alors qu'il
frfrôle la centaine, avec la lu,
pepeut-être que ce sera une
trtrentaine. Les météores, les
ététoiles filantes les plus
brbrillantes seront toujours
vivisibles, donc c'est amplement
susuffisant pour passer une bele
sosoirée sous les étoiles.
- - C'est parce que la lune émet
bebeaucoup de lumière ?
- - La lune qui émet un genre de
popollution lumineuse naturelle,
sisi on peut dire donc cela va
mamasquer les étoiles filantes s
plplus faibles mais les plus
brbrillantes seront nettement
vivisibles. Donc si on a la chae
dede s'éloigner un peu de la
popollution lumineuse, on risque
d'd'avoir un beau spectacle
pependant les prochains jours.
- - Parlez-nous des activités qi
auauront lieu à l'observatoire,
ququ'est-ce qui est prévu cette
anannée?
- - En est tellement heureux cee
anannée d'en faire venir à une
foformule traditionnelle pour ls
PePerséides au mont Mégantic, au
cocoeur des installations dédiés
auau public. Les gens sont invis
àà venir passer la nuit avec
nonous, amener leur chaise, leur
mamatelas de sol, à compter les
ététoiles filantes, il y a des
prprésentations, des activités,
c'c'est une grande fête des
ététoiles au mont Mégantic mais
auaussi partout au Québec, les
clclubs amateurs d'astronomes
ororganisent des activités. Où n
MéMégantic, les réservations sot
dédéjà complètes mais il reste s
plplaces en réservation pour les
gegens qui veulent venir profitr
dudu spectacle avec nous.
L Les Perséides, ces belles
ététoiles filantes que l'on va
papasser dans le ciel, c'est
imimpressionnant, mais il faut
sasavoir que c'est causé par des
paparticules de la taille d'un
grgrain de sable, de toutes
pepetites particules qui ont été
sesemées par une comète, qui
rérépond au nom de ses
dédécouvreurs, qui fait le toure
lala terre en un peu plus d'une
cecentaine d'années et qui revit
dede temps en tetemps enrichir e
ririvière de poussière cosmique,
ququ'elle sème lors de son passe
auautour du soleil parce qu'elle
sese désagrège un peu tout au lg
dede sa trajectoire, il y a cete
ririvière de poussière cosmique
quque la terre traverse chaque
anannée au mois d'août à peu prs
àà la même date. Il faut savoir
ququ'il y a d'autre pluie
d'd'étoiles filantes, les
PePerséides sont les plus connus
mamais d'autres arrivent l'hive,
dodonc les Perséides, ce n'est s
lala seule pluie d'étoiles
fifilantes dans l'année.
- - Est-ce que c'est quand même
popossible de les observer si on
esest en ville, parce qu'on sait
quque la pollution lumineuse cae
unun peu la vue des étoiles
fifilantes?
- - C'est tout à fait possible,l
fafaut être un peu plus patient,
évévidemment, on va en voir un u
momoins mais si on est patient,n
ririsque fort d'avoir une
trtraversée de celle-ci on peut
trtrouver un parent, un endroiùu
l'l'horizon est un peu plus
dédégagé, pas trop de gros
luluminaires ni de gratte-ciel à
ccôté. C'est tendre sur le dos t
obobserver la plus grande partie
dede ciel possible, et quand on
jajase avec nos amis et nos
fafamilles, on garde les yeux sr
lele ciel pour être sûr de ne ps
enen manquer une.
- - On a vu dans certaines
mumunicipalités, dans le haut
SaSaint-François, à population t
apappelée à éteindre son éclaire
exextérieur pour mieux voir les
ététoiles filantes parce qu'on
enenvisage de faire un appel por
quque ça se fasse un peu partout
auau Québec?
- - C'est une très belle
ininitiative, c'est une très bee
ididée. Il y a des discussions
évéventuellement pour étendre
l'l'initiative. Les Perséides,
c'c'est la fête des étoiles, c't
prpresque dans la culture au
QuQuébec d'observer les étoiles
dodonc c'est un très bon moment
popour sensibiliser la populatin
auaux spectacles du ciel étoilé,
ququi est magnifique durant les
PePerséides mais également à
l'l'année. Un spectacle qui est
memenacé aujourd'hui à cause dea
popollution lumineuse. Ça montre
ququ'on peut réduire notre
écéclairage pour concilier les
bebesoins de sécurité et la
prprésence du spectacle du ciel
ététoilé. Alors oui, à suivre pr
l'l'an pro